retour maintenant sur la crise des
banlieues qui a parfois à coucher des
initiatives heureuses
ainsi un groupe de jeunes d'une cité de
bondy tient depuis le début de l'année
un journal quotidien sur internet un
blog qui connaît un vrai succès un
éditeur a même décidé d'en faire un
livre
ces jeunes apprennent peu à peu le
métier de journaliste tout est parti
d'un hebdomadaire suisse qui a installé
ses reporters là-bas sur place pendant
les événements enquête mathias hillion
guillaume viard curiosité helvètes
pendant trois mois des journalistes
suisses ont occupé ce petit local à la
porte
très vite fracturée là ils ont rédigé à
tour de rôle une chronique quotidienne
sur internet
le bondy blog 400 articles plus tard il
passe le relais ainsi jeunes de la
commune direction lausanne pour une
semaine de formation payée par le
journal kamel el houari et hakim à
zhouqu compte encore du mal à y croire
voire déçus ça arrivait en banlieue
surtout dans le 93 20 ça fait bizarre
parlons project ten blague même des
bonheurs qui courait cosc des flics ces
défis camouflé pour mir fini avec le
chapeau le journaliste à l'origine de
l'aventuré
serge michel prix albert londres en 2001
pour un reportage en iran est le premier
à s'être installés à bondy l'aventurette
au coin de la rue aussi je veux dire
c'est vrai que peut-être le fait qu'on
essuie c est que pour nous d'aller en
banlieue parisienne c'était l'étranger
déjà ça peut être facilité ce regard
décalé ce regard un petit peu qui
s'intéressent à ce qui s'y passe c'est
ici dans la rédaction de l'hebdo que les
jeunes de bondy sont initiés au
journalisme question au bord du lac
léman
comment parler du quartier parfois le
critiquer tout en y habitant on peut
parler de choses ou de gens sont excités
on peut on peut parler de sujets sans
forcément les attaquer de front
il est évident que nous faudra qu on
cohabite après avec avec les gens qu'on
décrira
de retour à bondy exercice pratique une
semaine plus tard comme les jeunes qui
l'interrogent kamel el houari est à la
recherche d'un emploi qu'est ce que vous
faites dans la vie des gens premièrement
je cherche plutôt que sur le très simple
il y avait les ailes que ça partout j'en
dis calmez vous les jeunes chats vont
trouver du taf
mais là ça fait trois mois je vois rien
du tout et ça existe encore des
embrouilles entre cités entre quartiers
aux accents son coach particulier pour
cette première interview
un journaliste suisse venu tout
spécialement pour l'occasion et n'hésite
pas dans ce genre de situation a de
montesson thibault c'est aussi ça qui
titre de l'article choisi par kamel de
quel côté suis-je sur bondy blog.fr tous
les thèmes sont abordés démonstration à
l'heure de la conférence de rédaction
diluer l'information dans toutes les
positions soient aussi pourquoi avait-il
voilà si c'était quelque chose de forcé
ou si c'était voulu de sa part elle est
issue d'une famille polygame contexte
familial la rédaction du blog un agrégé
d'économie des chômeurs des lycéennes
l'une d'elles est sélectionnée pour
intégrer sciences po après le site
internet le livre publié par un grand
éditeur
son lancement est l'occasion pour les
blogueurs de montrer au maire de bondy
leur maîtrise de l'interview sentence à
lisieux tout ce qui se passe là à ce
qu'ils ont lu le super u site à sa faute
de la droite
est ce que vous serez prêt entrons en
tant que maire socialiste donc nous ait
fait des erreurs oui bien sûr qu'il faut
reconnaître ses erreurs titulaire d'une
maîtrise de commerce international
chaouki à roy est agent d'entretien dans
le métro sur le blog il ne dénonce pas
seulement la discrimination à l embauche
mais aussi les casseurs des
manifestations anti cpe qui ternissent
écrit-il
l'image des cités ne comptez pas sur les
blogueurs pour édulcorer leurs banlieues